bonsoir et bienvenue dans municipal 2014
nous allons passer en revue l'actualité
des élections maintenant un peu plus de
10 jours du premier tour ce sera le
dimanche 23 mars et d'abord les
candidats avaient jusqu'au 6 mars pour
déposer leur listes et pour les
prochaines élections municipales 13218
candidatures précisément ont été
enregistrés dans les 262 communes des
Yvelines c'est plus que lors des
précédents scrutin de
liste le département des ivelines compte
262 communes dans les villes de plus de
1000 habitants elles sont au nombre de
145 389 listes ont été déposées c'est 10
% de plus que lors du précédent scrutin
de liste en détail dans celle qui nous
concerne tout d'abord les communes de
l'agglomération à gui en cours il n'y
aura donc que deux listes celle du maire
sortant socialiste François de ligé et
celle du candidat de l'UMP udi Ladislas
scura à La Verrière également de listes
celle du maire sortant communiste Alain
jage et celle de l'UMP udi Nicolas
d'Inville même cas de figure à Mani
lesamau le maire sortant socialiste
Bertrand Ouillon sera opposé à la
candidate de l'UMP udi Aurore berger à
Montini le Bretonneux ils seront trois
la liste du maire sortant Michel logier
pour l'UMP udi et le modem celle de
Vivien Gasque soutenue par le Parti
socialiste et la liste de Sylvain
griison pour le rassemblement bleu
marine le parti frontiste à hencour les
électeurs auront le choix entre quatre
listes celle du maire sortant
Jean-Michel Fourgous celle de la gauche
avec Michel bessau la liste génération
solidaire de Christian Nicole et la
liste frontiste de Nicolas Boer à voisin
le Bretonneux les quatre listes
annoncées iront jusqu'au bout les
électeurs auront donc le choix entre
trois listes de droite et du centre
celle du maire sortant soutenue
notamment par l'UMP l'UDI Alexis Biet
celle de son ancienne première adjointe
Alexandra Rosetti et celle de son ancien
mer adjoint aux finances Jean-Louis
tison Jean H lui représentera les
valeurs de la gauche ces trappes qui
présentent le plus grand nombre de
listes C celle du ma sortant socialiste
guim Malandin celle de d'tman nassrou
pour l'umpudi Luc miseray pour le Front
de gauche et deux autres listes l'une
menée par Mohamed camli et l'autre par
Sliman
bousana dans les autres villes alentour
à noté qu'à mourpa le départ du ma
sortant George Mougeot attise les
appétits C listes ont été déposé dans
cette commune à saint-ciire l'école les
électeurs auront le choix entre cinq
listes différentes au clés sousbois
quatre listes ont été é déposé dont une
liste de dernières minutes menée par
Claude de bosser l'pidi à Plaisir la
mère sortant UMP Joséphine colmberger
aura face à elle une liste frontiste
d'Alexander Nikolic la liste socialiste
de Bernard Ansar et une liste divivers
gauche de jamagiati les élections seront
plus calmes à boisarcy et à coanière
dans ces communes seulement deux listes
vont s'affronter à chaque fois le
premier tour des élections municipales
aura lieu le dimanche 23
mars et on poursuit cette émission avec
d'autres échos de campagne à encour le
groupe d'opposition et l'encour au
centre n'officialise pas de liste
Dominique loochon Virginie berniè et
Laurent verra conseillers municipaux ne
seront donc pas présents pour des
élections ils n'ont pas réussi à
rassembler explique-t-il dans un
communiqué et il ne donne pas pardon de
consignes de vote et les électes
deslancour ont donc le choix entre
quatre listes celle du maire sortant
Jean-Michel Fourgous la liste de gauche
de Michel bessaau la liste frontiste de
Nicolas Boer et la liste sans étiquette
de Christian Nicole alors pour ces
municipales vous le savez les écteurs
vont devoir désigner leurs représentants
au sein du conseil municipal mais sur la
même liste dans l'urne ils vont aussi
voter pour les représentants au conseil
communautaire et auparavant ces
conseillers au Conseil Communautaire
étaient élus par leur père et non au
suffrage direct alors du coup ça change
un peu la donne parce que les partis
politiques jusque-là surtout préoccupé
par les questions locales forment
également un projet pour l'agglomération
Europe Écologie Les Verts le Parti
communiste et le Parti socialiste ont
d'ailleurs tenu samedi dernier les
assises où étaient réunis les huit
candidats tête de liste de la gauche sur
550 an en Yveline il souhaite proposer
une plateforme de réflexion commune
autour de thématiques comme le
développement économique les services
pour tous et la démocratie
intercommunale et peut-être en réponse à
ses assises de la gauche les candidats
de la droite et du centre de 50 ans en
yelin organiseent eux ce samedi matin
une conférence de presse pour présenter
leur projet de l'agglomération et puis
ça a été une campagne c'est également
une campagne qui est également ponctuée
par des visites de personnalité Henry
guenou vous le découvrez médiatique
député de la 3e circonscription est venu
dimanche dernier soutenir la M sortante
des clés sous- bois Véronique coté
Millard autre invité politique Benoît
amont le ministre délégué à l'économie
sociale et solidaire candidat à trappe
est venu de son côté soutenir Michel
bessau à hencour un ministre très
présent sur le terrain de
l'agglomération puisqu'il sera ce
mercredi au côté de Vivien Gasque à
Montini le bretonux et puis autre leader
socialiste c'est Harlem desir le premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste il sera
lui soir au côté d'Isabelle tisint-jean
elle est candidate à
Versailles allez nous poursuivons
maintenant cette émission avec des
portraits de candidats nous allons du
côté de voisin le Bretonneux ils sont
quatre en Liss trois affichent une
étiquette de droite et du centre et un
candidat reprend les valeurs de la
gauche quatre candidatures se sont
déclarées pour ces municipales à voisin
le Bretonneux c'est la copie conforme ou
presque de l'élection de 2008 il y a 6
ans il y avait trois candidats à droite
et un candidat représentant les valeurs
de la gauche 6 ans plus tard bis
repétita trois candidats reprenant les
valeurs de la droite et du centre et un
candidat divers gauche les candidats de
2014 ne seront pas des inconnus il y a
tout d'abord le maire sortant Alexis
Biet 59 ans vissinois depuis 1982 et
maire depuis 95 le déclic en politique
Alexis Biet l'a eu en 1988 alors qu'il
soutenait Raymond B au présidentiel
l'échec du candidat centr triste l'a
décidé c'est le déclic qui m'a fait
adhérer à un parti politique en disant
qu'il fallait une organisation que un
homme quel que soi ses ses idées sa
valeur et bien ça ne suffisait pas en
1995 alors qu'il est élu au sein de la
majorité Alexy Biet monte sa liste
contre le maire sortant René Van Dam
depuis il a été régulièrement réélu il
brigue un 4e mandat et met en avant son
expérience il y a l'expérience qui est
importante surtout dans le contexte
actuel hein où il y a une certaine
disette financière donc l'expérience je
pense sera un atout et puis une équipe
assez renouvelée de la moitié de
l'équipe qui est renouvelée qui jeune
qui apporte du 109 de des compétences
aussi qui est très très motivé au
service de voisins sa priorité pour ces
élections l'équilibre en terme de
logement en terme économique pour
favoriser le approchement domicile
travaille et en terme d'animation pour
éviter que voisin devienne une ville
d'ortoir il aura face à lui deux listes
de la droite et du centre peut-être la
plus emblématique Alexandra Rosetti 46
ans élue sur la liste d'Alexis Biet et
2001 d'abord en qualité de Maire
Adjointe puis première m adjointte en
2008 l'élu centriste de l'UDI a quitté
le conseil municipal en octobre dernier
pour monter sa propre liste de moins en
moins de confiance de part et d'autres
je pense des des deux côtés et parce que
j'estimais donc que les choix qui
étaient fait ne me convenaient pas
l'économie son cheval de bataille la
ville n'a plus les mêmes ressources
estime-t-elle alors il faut faire des
choix moi j'ai envie de proposer qu'on
se recentre sur les besoins des
habitants qu'on ait des projets qui sont
vraiment je dirais plutôt simple
raisonnable et arrêter toutes les
dépenses de prestige d'étiquett de label
de paillettes parce que je crois qu'on
on est plus en capacité de les absorber
aut trxe de campagne l'urbanisme et la
circulation avec selon elle cette
nécessité de porter une voix forte il
faut aller dans les instances il faut
porter des demandes et je pense qu'il
faut pas lâcher en fait c'est un peu
l'idée quoi j'ai pas le sentiment qu'on
a été très présent qu'on a demandé
grandchose pour voisins pour ce scrutin
Alexandra Rosetti avait tendu la main au
troème candidat de droite Jean-Louis
tison mais l'union au premier tour n'a
pas été trouvée c'est sur le terrain des
mouettes que l'on retrouve Jean-Louis
tison 63 ans il habite voisin le
Bretonneux depuis 89 rapidement
conseiller de quartier il est élu en
2001 maire adjoint finance auprès
d'Alexis Biet en 2008 c'est la sission
il suit la liste montée par le duo Joë
lenant et Catherine perodo et pour ce
nouveau scrutin il prend la tête d'une
liste divivers droite moi ce qui me
motive c'estes voisins et moi mes
valeurs c'est d'abord le le l'identité
de voisins qu'on est en train de perdre
c'est la proximité des espaces verts je
veux conserver cette Proxim cette zone
de transition entre la proximité des
espaces verts du parc naturel et le
centre intensif son autre axe de camp
bien entendu les finances les impôts qui
augmentent de 30 % l'espace de 6 ans
alors que j'avais laissé une situation
particulièrement net un endettement qui
a explosé pendant la période de 6 ans
qu'est-ce que je vois les gens me disent
mais monsieur tison on va plus pouvoir
rester sur voisin il prend donc la tête
d'une liste qu'il définit du centre et
de la droite et n'a pas sollicité
d'investiture nous sommes candidats aux
élections municipales on venez se
présenter à vous connaît un peu vos
besoins seul candidat représentant les
valeurs de la gauche Jean ha vcinois
depuis
1979 à 68 ans il siège dans l'opposition
depuis 95 ah oui oui oui voisin a besoin
d'un nouveau dynamisme d'une vision à
long terme des des problèmes et des et
des réalisations voisin a un cadre de
vie quand même tout à fait intéressant
il y a des nombreuses écoles qui sont
performantes et qui permettent aux
jeunes aux enfants et aux jeunes de se
développer dans l'éducation il y a de
nombreuses associations qui sont très
dynamiques avec un réseau de bénévole
qui ne compte pas son temps donc il y
avait de nombreux atouts et en fait ces
atouts ne sont pas valorisés aujourd'hui
Jean h souhaite une meilleure
harmonisation des constructions et des
espaces vert des logements plus
accessibles aux jeunes et aux familles
concrétiser l'aménagement du terrain de
la remise et offrir un axe
environnemental on aidera les finois à
trouver la meilleure voie pour
l'isolation et pour la réduction de de
leur consommation énergétique Jean ha
regarde d'un œil lointain les divisions
de la droite et du centre dont il n'a
pas bénéficié jusqu'à présent pour
remporter l'élection si ça me permet de
gagner la mairie je dis bravo mais voilà
je je je laisse à la droite le soix de
régler ses comptes nous verrons comment
les électeurs vont vivre cette version
2014 en 2008 il avait fallu deux tours
pour départager les candidats et en
passer par une triangulaire Alexis Biet
était sorti gagnant avec près de 40 %
des
voix et autre ville qui focalise
l'attention Rambouillet le maire sortant
l'emblématique Gérard Larcher élu en
1983 ne se représente pas Marc Robert un
ancien de son équipe a été désigné pour
mener la liste UMP mais le départ de
Gérard Larcher attise bien entendu les
appétits une demi-douzaine de listes
s'est déclaré Wilfred Richi fait le
point mars 2008 trois listes mais un
seul tour à Rambouillet Gérard Larcher
en poste depuis 1983 l'emporte une fois
de plus avec près de 58 % des suffrages
une victoire nette dont rêve sans doute
Marc Robert 54 ans il est né a grandi
dans cette ville avant de siéger dans la
majorité pendant 19 ans au côté de celui
qui l'a aujourd'hui à doubé pour mener
campagne rouiller son identité sa
qualité de vie c'est un élément que tous
les rambolitains quel qu'ils soit je
dirais souhaitent conserver et voir
approfondir à partir de là tous les
projets et toutes les les sujets que
nous allons aborder se poseront de façon
à pouvoir poursuivre cette cette
particularité qui est une vraie
identitaire embouillée dans S sa
situation je dirais au au au au au
finfond d'île-de-fance ouverte désormais
sur la région Centre je serais très
attentif pour que notamment au niveau de
l'urbanisme nous soyons
qualitatif répondant quand même aux
besoins de la ville mais de toute façon
en maintenant cette identité
rambolitaine j'allais dire pour
maintenir la croissance démographique et
soutenir les familles agir pour la
sécurité quelquesunes de ces
propositions mais Marc Robert doit aussi
compter au centre droit avec avec la
candidature de Grégoire Leclerc pas
d'investiture officielle pour sa liste
mais le président de la Fédération
française des auto-entrepreneurs a
décidé à 31 ans de mener campagne avec
pour mot d'ordre le dynamisme on vient
apporter des idées on vient apporter de
la modernité de l'innovation on vient
apporter aussi des comparaisons avec ce
qui peut se faire ailleurs pour essayer
de de faire changer les choses que ce
soit au niveau de l'attractivité pour
les entreprises au niveau de la famille
c'est une ville qui est très familial au
niveau effectivement de de la relation
entre les générations entre les
personnes âgées et les enfants qui sont
en crèche en garderie dans les dans les
écoles maternelles et primaires on vient
apporter des idées aussi sur la la
gestion des finances c'est un point très
très important de cette campagne
peut-être les parties traditionnelles ne
s'occupent pas assez du quotidien et
s'occupent peut-être trop des des enjeux
et on essaie de renverser la vapeur à
gauche la division est de mise Jean-Luc
trottignon un temps soutenu par le PS
partira finalement avec une étiquette
divivers gauche en raison de son
ralliment avec le groupe centriste des
ivelines déjà candidat en 2008 se perd
de 5 enfant de 54 ans mise sur le
tourisme l'emploi ou encore
l'environnement maîre mot la
transparence et nous on mettra tout sur
la table et on proposera aux citoyens de
participer réellement au aux décisions
par exemple pour l'aménagement de la rue
qui est derrière moière moi la rue
principale de de Rambouillet la rue De
Gaulle on fera une consultation
citoyenne avec les diverses possibilités
allant du statut quo jusqu'à la rue
piétonne c'est une nouvelle façon de
concevoir la démocratie c'est un des
axes principaux où les
citoyens apprennent on leur apprend à
contrôler leurs élus et le travail de
leurs élus ceux qui en ont besoin et on
les fait participer euh pour qu'il y ait
plus de décision du type bah les
empreunes toxique pris par la la
majorité actuelle avec à peu près 8
millions d'euros de pénalité à payer aux
banques sur les 15 ans à venir c'est de
l'argent jeter par les fenêtres Jean-Luc
trottignon qui s'est également fait
connaître avec son engagement au sein
d'anticors association de lutte contre
la corruption en politique aussi à
gauche David Jutier pour Europe Écologie
les vers a vu le PS se rallier à sa
cause après la sission avec Jean-Luc
trtig le PS a choisi de de nous soutenir
et et d'appeler ses sympathisants à
voter pour nous on s'en on s'en félicite
avec sa liste Rambouillet écologique et
citoyenne David Jutier mise sur la
différence on a des mesures qui sont
originales qui sont différentes de tout
ce que peuvent proposer les les autres
les autres partis sur notamment des
politiques très transversale nous on a
une une approche globale on a communiqué
la semaine dernière par exemple sur une
politique transversale AG ulture
alimentation santé ça c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait original donc on
souhaitait porter ce ce projet de
manière autonome ça nous semblait assez
logiqueonour pas d'alliance avec Europe
Écologie Les ver pour le Front de Gauche
parents d'élèves délégué du personnel
Catherine Drouin franchit le pas de la
politique dans la mouvance des idées
développées par Jean-Luc Mélenchon en
2012 à la présidentielle nos
propositions sont repos sur trois
piliers ces trois piliers sont la
citoyenneté la solidarité et l'écologie
reproche à la municipalité actuelle
c'est d'être en fait trop loin de de la
population d'être trop centré sur une
petite partie une petite couche de de de
la population de Rambouillet un petit
noyau et et de pas être à l'écoute de
l'ensemble de la population et notamment
de ceux qui ont vraiment besoin qu'on
soit leur écoute une ville au service de
la population avec des conseils de
quartier un agenda 21 et des PME locales
pour favoriser les circuits courts dans
la distribut alimentire plus de 10
listes sur le département pour le Front
national une première de mémoire de
militants qui pourront donc cette année
voter Rambouillet pour Philipp Chevrier
le secrétaire départemental de la
formation le péniste a réussi à monter
sa liste et entend faire aussi bien que
lors des dernières législatives
lorsqu'il avait totalisé plus de 10 %
des suffrages dans la
circonscription
j'ai été militant au Parti socialiste
pendant un temps très court qui m'a
permis de comprendre assez vite les
erreurs du Parti socialiste et ensuite
je suis donc j'ai rencontré Jean-Marie
Le Pen et j'ai adhéré très rapidement au
Front national salarié d'Air France il
estime que les idées de son parti
passent de mieux en mieux sur le terrain
les fait Marine Le Pen quand on commence
à regarder la vie rambolitaine il est
clair que un certain nombre de choses
fonctionnent mal comme la circulation
automobile la circulation automobile
c'est une vraie catastrophe à
Rambouillet alors qu'il y a des
solutions et des solutions qui ne sont
pas forcément très coûteuse mais il
faudra sans doute faire des travaux bien
entendu il faudra faire des efforts
aussi au plan de la
sécurité dans son programme on retrouve
également baisse des impôts rénovation
des logements sociaux et soutien au
commerces locaux en aménageant notamment
les
parkings voilà et puis vous le savez la
rédaction de TVfil 78 organise des
débats entre les candidats des
différentes villes de l'agglomération et
alentour nous vous proposons de revoir
les meilleurs moments la semaine
dernière Wifred Richy recevait les
candidats de la ville de MPa alors même
cas de figure car enouillet le maire
sortant George Mougeot ne se représente
pas et du coup les candidatures sont
nombreuses depuis bon nombre d'années
avec George Mougeot nous avons
transformé considérablement la ville de
morpa quand on se rappelle l'image qui
était un petit peu stalinienne dans les
années 80 on a aujourd'hui une ville
agréable apaisée apaisante nous voulons
conserver à M repas cette image
d'apaisement et c'est aussi l'occasion
de rendre hommage à toutes celles et
ceux qui m'ont rejoint pour constituer
cette liste citoyenne porteuse de
propositions convaincu déterminé et
pacifique protéger le caractère vill à
la campagne de morpa de mettre beaucoup
d'investissements dans dans les écoles
dans la sécurité surtout la démocratie
locale morpa a besoin en tout cas les
morpasiens ont besoin d'être reconsultés
sur l'avenir de morpa et c'est essentiel
à morpa il y a une page qui est en train
de se tourner et évidemment aucun
d'entre nous n'a envie de l'avoir raté
parce que l'enjeu est est important
quand je disais tout à l'heure en
commençant il va falloir à la fois
préserver innover c'est un équilibre qui
va être difficile mais il me semble et
ça c'est cette fois le professionnel qui
parle les années prochaines vont être
dures elles vont être très difficiles et
donc la qualité d'un prochain maire ce
sera aussi d'être capable de financer
sans toucher massivement à l'impôt donc
moi je représente la liste une liste de
gauche de large rassemblement le PS
Europe Écologie les vers le Parti
communiste le Parti radical de gauche et
la société ville donc c'est une liste de
large rassemblement le le fil conducteur
et qui est très important pour nous
redonner la parole au morpasien avec les
comités de quartier échanger sur les
projets et qui soi parties prenante et
qui construisent et que nous
construisons la ville ensemble on a
aussi des projets intéressants dont on a
pas parler c'est-à-dire une régie
publique de l'eau par exemple et et
là-dessus on a des idées à faire et puis
sur les impôts par contre on pense que
effectivement s'il y a un projet qui
mérite d'être financé effectivement il
faut y mettre le prix et ça peut être
intéressant pour certains 25 ans de
pouvoir ou d'exercice de pouvoir par
certaines équipes c'est à la fois bien
pour certains et pas bien pour d'autres
je pense que on a des choses à proposer
et à changer parce qu' des choses qui
n'ont pas été la démocratie qui n'a pas
bien fonctionné l'intercommunalité qu'on
a loupé voilà un débat de près d'un
heure3 que vous pouvez retrouver sur
notre site internet dédié au municipal
autres débat celui-ci il concerne la
commune d'élencour comme je vous
l'indiqué en début d'émission ils sont
quatre à se présenter et l'un des thèmes
abordés lors de ce débat ça a été la
sécurité monsieur Fourgous nous nous
explique depuis qu'il est arrivé à la
mairie d'élancour l'insécurité a baissé
de 30 %. hein donc je bon chiffre bravo
Monsieur voilà donc je me demande ce que
ça devait être avant alors par exemple
la pharmacie braqué il débou il
dépouillait les buralistes trois
policiers blessés dans un accident l'
indice coupé pendant plus de 2 heures il
avait sauté dans le canal pour échapper
aux forces de l'ordre le gérant du salon
de coiffure agressé à coup de barre de
fer le la proposition c'est de donner
plus de moyens à la police municipale
qui travaillera de concert avec la
police avec la police nationale je sais
que la police nationale vous l'avez
également mis dans une situation
catastrophique l'UMP et le PS parce que
construction je vous l'ai dit en terme
de sécurité d'un commissariat de la
ville nouvelle donc le siège va être en
cours bon on va y intégrer le
laboratoire le pbsl avec EADS avec
toutes les meilleures entreprises qui
vont qui vont donc s'acoler laissez-moi
terminer laiss-mo TER
ensuite on va étendre la la vidéo au
protection donc au moins de 50 % pour é
enc cours l'essentiel c'est
effectivement de redonner des moyens
humains parce que sans moyens humains on
n arrive pas autre point essentiel il ne
faut pas que les personnes se sentent en
insécurité et il y a un des moyens c'est
de créer du lien de la convivialité
entre les gens que les gens se
connaissent et justement pouvoir
dénoncer ce qui ne va pas la délinquence
peut être prévenue mais en travaillant à
la base et en en travaillant sur le
problème de fond c'està-dire si les si
les jeunes notamment ont de quoi
s'occuper ont de quoi créer leur vie ont
de quoi créer leur emploi non il y aura
beaucoup moins de problèmes de fait donc
évidemment il faut travailler avec les
forces de police parce que c'est eux qui
vont pouvoir permettre de répandre ce
sentiment de sécurité que il n'y a
peut-être pas toujours voilà et puis
d'autres prochains débats à découvrir
sur notre antenne ou à revoir sur notre
site internet dédié au municipal ce
concernant Guillon courour les CLIS
sousbois ou encore Montini le Bretonneux
et d'ailleurs sur notre site Internet
vous pouvez retrouver l'ensemble des
candidat les informations les
concernants ainsi que les résultats du
dernier scrutin allez cette émission est
maintenant terminée merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain rendez-vous municipal
2014 ce sera mardi 18 mars nous serons
alors à 5 jours du premier tour de
scrutin bonne
soirée